chicken care
[Music]
celebrate me
Monday happy Monday
[Music]
happy Monday guys
happy Monday out there in the world
wherever you are if you're in a you know
if you're at if you're in York if you're
in your car right now are your truck you
know if you're in a van and you know and
you secretly you got them headphones on
you got a couple of kids in the back
they don't even need to be listening to
- you know - you're wild step-cousin
Theo right here because he might you
know just sometime I you know my brain
throws an expletive and it uses my face
to toss it into the universe and and so
yeah but wherever you are if you're
sitting at home soon I'll go up with a
loved one dude that sounds beautiful
there's nothing I wish more than that
that it's too beautiful or not even
beautiful in their own minds and it
doesn't even matter who thinks they're
beautiful I just hope that there's too
thick gay men out there just snuggled up
somewhere listening to this listening to
this bad chatter I don't know the
universe because that's something about
that makes me it doesn't make me feel
homoerotic but it just makes me feel
like you know what them big dogs is out
there you know staying natural and
having a good time and you know and
we're not uh you know they're not people
they're not not listening to a guy
because you know he's maybe different
than them and and I think about that but
wherever you are if you're listening to
this today I appreciate you being here
with me happy Monday January 15 the year
2017 in in time as far as we know and
the game I have the game on right now
and I paused it I have the Saints versus
the Minnesota Vikings and I'm home alone
it got to the point I was like I got to
do this podcast because I got to drive
to Brea and do a show I got to leave in
about an hour and fifteen minutes or
something so I'm like I gotta I can't
watch any more right now and I was so
amped up I'm like what's gonna happen
because the the Vikings made a field
goal and then the Saints made a field
goal and so then the Saints were in the
lead but the Vikings were getting the
ball back 25 seconds
a lot of time but I was like I just
gotta pause it because I don't know if I
knew if I watched and the Saints lost I
would be really upset or bummed out said
I'm gonna have that natural bum that
free bum you know bouncing all you know
inside of my walls so here I am and it's
pause I can see in the background it's
just like a picture of the sidelines on
the TV screen and it's paused so I'm
gonna have to get into that later on
thank you guys for joining us I want to
thank everybody that came out in Brea
this weekend and I want to apologize for
anybody that came to the Saturday night
Late Show things just got out of hand
you know like not with me really just in
the audience there was a lot of people
being loud you know some people was
upped up you know some people were snick
you know snickered up on that dust you
know and um and it just I think it
ruined some of the show and the staff
and I love the staff that works there
you know but they didn't do a good job
of holding it down there was no real
mediation of the room and I just want to
apologize to anybody that came out to
that Saturday Late Show and if I'm
heading back there in the future and you
want to come see a show hit me up and
I'll see if I can help out with some
tickets because I feel bad about that
because you guys didn't get the best
show because there was this these you
know some people were chirping and you
know I don't know what they were doing
taking each other's pulses or just being
just wild so you know but but anyhow
appreciate if you did come out and and I
had a nice week in a brave man a lot of
cool people came out so I was I was
grateful everybody that came through
what's going on man I got this coffee I
got dude my buddy sent me this coffee
for Christmas and this isn't an ad my
buddy sent me this coffee for Christmas
it says on there I just opened it it
says it's called cups coffee and it says
Guatemalan single-use or something or
one year old and I'm like damn this [ __ ]
sounds I just want coffee you know
saying I don't need to know you know I
don't need its birth certificate I want
[ __ ] coffee I want to not have to go
buy cocaine so I want to just use
something nach
I want coffee this [ __ ] got me making
that make me feel like I'm involved in
sex you know sex trafficking or
something this just says Guatemalan you
know 72 months or something on I'm like
what the hell man so now I'm drinking
coffee and I'm a little bit nervous and
I just don't want to get caught up in
some kind of you know who knows in the
future maybe they'll they'll bust a man
you know he used to drink coffee that
was only three years old you know no man
should be drinking coffee that hasn't
been aged where the beans haven't been
aged at least eighteen years and who
knows what's next they take him in out
of the universe they're trying to take
us out of the universe sometimes and I
know it's not an intention I think a lot
of this you know there's a there's a
strong female movement out there you
know it's like the whole world it's like
it's like Mother Nature herself is about
to just you know drop an egg you know
like she's just on that stration and
she's about to just drop an egg you know
and I don't even know where that egg
would just pop out of the earth I guess
just come rolling out of a dam maybe out
of the San Andreas Fault you know that
egg might end up out there and in a you
know in South Riverside or out towards
AI Anaheim who knows you know but I feel
like Mother Nature's just she's on that
you know she's on them tumbles he's got
them belly tumbles and she won't spicket
she wants pickles and chocolate because
she's having you know she's going
through some things and sometimes it has
to happen for things to even out you
know but damn they taken every
everybody's getting everybody's getting
called out for being wild and for being
too much Aziz Ansari just got that you
know there was a thing on the Internet
today
and you know the thing is when you first
time I read something now the first
thing I think is is this true who's
citing these sources there are there any
real sources you know the the website or
the thing was called babe net or
something was the company that was
saying this I never heard of them I
never heard of them in my life so but
the allegations that were out there were
just that he was on a date with a girl
he invited her over you know he was
trying to be nasty and be naughty with
her or he's trying to be I mean it
seemed like he was being aggressive if
from this girl's take you know and I'm
not discounting what she said
no clue you know there hasn't been any
like there hasn't been you know there's
no trial or anything here it doesn't
seem like so uh that's the strange thing
like I don't know is he being accused of
a crime if that's the case do you take
it to authorities are you just making it
aware and using his name so I guess some
of the movement the meet to if it's part
of the me to movement is a bit our times
up I think they changed it now two times
up is a little confusion to me in that
regard because I don't know what's you
know like I guess is just awareness
you're using somebody's name do they get
to say what they thought happened that
evening and I guess he will if he wants
to if he wants to know rebuttal it but
it's also you know people's perspective
of people's perspectives of what's going
on when something's going on can be
different you know they can be different
you know and we didn't all come from the
same history or the same experiences you
know like what if a man has only have
one girlfriend and she's real rowdy you
know when she likes the man to [ __ ]
you know put jingle bells in her ears
and you know beat her on the back with a
[ __ ] you know semi-hard billy club or
you know put um you know put egg yolks
on her legs and dip them in damn you
know plank of plank Oh toast chips and
[ __ ] or something like who knows and
then you show up at a girl's you know
then you show up on a date and you got a
sack I straight up you know toast crumbs
and of deep fryer and a couple of jingle
bells couple JB's and you're ready to
rock out you know it's like it's just
people's perspectives going into you
know their history has so much to do
with it so but it's why I mean here this
guy wakes up and and and you know maybe
maybe he does this kind of stuff all the
time and maybe he's you know a nasty cat
and maybe he this is something that you
know that needs to come out to help him
get better and maybe that's the way it's
being done now is just on a public scale
I mean I'm like the future
what do you I mean maybe in the future
to sign an agreement these are the
things I like these are the things I
don't
I mean we're becoming so you know you've
you you chime into an app I'm into these
six or seven different ideas and someone
has to agree to them and ah it's wild
it's just it's a different you know
there's just a lot going on there's a
lot going on a lot of factors going on
but I don't know who won the game yet I
do not know who won the game I do not
know who won the game we got some good
calls that came in man and I'm not
jumping of those just yet but we have to
we have an interview I got I have to do
a call-out to a lovely young lady here
in just a second who's gonna be on the
hotline because we brought up well first
I got a call in uh-hum all over the
episode man this this uh this Guatemalan
six-year-old has got me
chirping out here man we had a call over
the weekend that came in about Hawaii
and this was from Josh in Hawaii here we
go yo this is Josh calling in from the
Island of Hawaii and yeah I'm just
calling you uh after a little
post-nuclear apocalyptic scare that we
had this morning I woke up to a an Amber
Alert saying there was a inbound
ballistic missile headed to the Island
of Hawaii
Rising Sun my homework and I basically
woke up into a scarier reality than the
nightmare I was having and there was
about thirty minutes where yeah that was
that was a real that was a real reality
man yeah I was just constantly updating
my Twitter trying to figure out what the
[ __ ] going on
nobody's saying this is a false alarm
and I'm walking around outside just
looking at my neighbor's trying to
figure if we're about to be bombed by
Kim Kim Seong Joon whatever whatever
that dude's name is over there anyways
Kim Jong Il baby and I'm gonna say this
you might want to get that man's name
under your tongue you know just because
if he shows up that's probably the first
question he's gonna ask us when he takes
over what's my name what's my
[ __ ]
and if you do that most people are not
gonna know it some young lamb boy you're
out there gonna chop you down right
there
chip choppity chopping to say that dude
somebody's gonna say your name is chip
chop lamb young lamb somebody's gonna
general so people are going to have the
worst ideas and they're gonna take it
they're gonna take you out so I think
his name is Kim jong-il Kim jong-il the
problem is they keep killing these Kim
Jones you know you little Kim Jon grows
up kills big Kim Jong so he can be the
bkj and then another little little Kim
Jong grows up and kills another B KJ and
it just keeps going Kim Jong Hill on and
on you know it's the race it'd be cold
it if it was a Kim Jong Oh Jo that'd be
dope and he came out with a little bit
of a Latino flare you know kind of like
he um you know like he just showed up on
Monday Night Raw one night was like Kim
Jong ah but I can't imagine that did I
you know there was a there was a imagine
now that moment were you telling me for
30 minutes you thought this was a
reality that their ballistic middle
first of all out after Google ballistic
so that I'm gonna start right there like
are these fun like what kind of missiles
horthy he's like who's like do I does
not have to be within 20 feet of where
it went like what am i up against but
can you imagine that for 30 minutes you
know I mean I wonder how many meet two
occurrences happen just during that 30
minutes because if I'm somewhere and
they say you got 30 minutes left
the countdown is here dude you can I'll
tell you this I'm gonna probably tell
them I'm gonna throw down about 300
milligrams of sigh Alice and finally
start talking to the women I've been
afraid to talk to most of my life that's
exactly what I'm gonna do you know I
might have to take a dude down with long
hair if he uses good conditioner and I
never see his face and I walk up to him
from behind
and just say hey you know ma'am are you
in a wild stuff and do it like you know
like I would never want to see the front
of him
but yeah dude I mean that's 30 minute
countdown I I'd love to know what you
did in that time well here's the thing
you had to be look the first thing you
probably did was look on look more is
this real but if nobody knows if it's
real and I think Hawaii didn't even make
the announcement until later in the day
to say it was an accident
or I'm guessing it took 30 minutes you
just said that 30 minutes right now
something says you got 30 minutes what
would you do I'd probably drive over to
somebody that I love I would honestly it
would be it would be a girl and I'm
trying to flee tried to have sex I
talked to my family you know what I
would have my family on speakerphone
talking to them and then quietly trying
to have sex with a girl who also wanted
to have sex with me
so I'll be trying to [ __ ] quietly so
that my family didn't know that was
going on you know and so me and the girl
could both enjoy each other's company
but at the same time trying to get my
love I love yous in you know she's like
did you just come back I'm like no
that's tears those are tears I'm talking
to my family this is a really sad 20
minutes right there this is a really sad
time we're coming through because the
world is ending
sorry that's a little vulgar man I don't
usually get that vulgar but that's just
I think it's this coffee man and it's
the game it's the excitement and also I
think man you know like and I appreciate
that call Josh and if there are things
going on in the world and you are a live
reporter on the scene of something it
can be a it could be anything it could
be a drug deal it could be a you know
post coitus with you and your mate it
could be you know you just shot an
animal your buddy just shot it if
there's something going on that are you
know if there's an earthquake or there's
that bullet the Hawaiian missile
practice whatever's going on you know
and you were live reporter on the scene
hit that hotline drop us that
information and we can play it because
that was nice to have Josh callin and
let us know what's happening out there
in Hawaii we had a great call that came
in on last week's episode and this was
it right here i'ma play it and then
we're gonna we're gonna call a lovely
young lady who's gonna be able to fill
us in on some information
here we go let's hear it hey Theo this
is JEP from down in Alabama and I was
calling you about dead porn stars man
had two of the greatest passed away in
late 2017 well now they've left behind
all this material and I feel like a lot
of people that are you know scrolling
through these porn sites and stuff they
may not know the girls are dead what are
your thoughts on our people jerking it
to dead porn stars man and you know and
some people would listen to this
question like all that Stu who cares
it's stupid about pornography and I and
I know this show you know this episode
we've had a little bit of smut chatter
you know we've been talking about things
that are bits mudda SH and I'm this
isn't good this show isn't devolving
into something smut ish but but this was
a good question this is a good question
and and I don't really think that I you
know I'm gonna give you my two cents in
a minute but first I'm gonna call I've
got a lovely young lady here her name is
Zoe Munroe you can check her out she's a
pornographic star pornographic actress
and she's in you know what it's tempting
here because she isn't you know she is
uh she's out there dance and you know in
the in the dark arts and she's a real
professional when she is uh she's good
at which she does I fell victim to it
many times you wasn't on my home
computer and I'm gonna give her a call
right now and and see what she thinks
about this very topic hello hello Zoe
Monroe what I'm doing good how are you
are you taking bong rips on a hammock
huh yep you ever tried to do a bunch of
cocaine and just stay in a hammock you
know I don't have well it's hard to do I
think it's probably easier to stay in a
hammock on pot yeah
because cocaine will make you want to
get out of a hammock you know at one
point I felt like I was just trapped in
some of these net you know but we had a
great call that came in on our podcast
this week and uh you know I'm a fan of
your work on my fan of you personally I
think you're a real sweetheart yeah you
are anytime I've been around you always
make me laugh and you're you know you're
a big pet owner you got a big heart and
you have a nice you know body and
everything that I've seen on the on the
internet and so yeah yeah I have I was
just telling just saying on on the
podcast and I've definitely fallen
victim to some of your work over the
years thank you very much but we had a
caller that called in and he said his
question was is you know last year you
guys lost some some popular pornographic
actors and actresses I think but in the
in your industry is it okay or what are
your thoughts on Matt on people
masturbating and not knowing if these
these actors and actresses are dead to
be fantasies and like comedians do what
they do you want to make people laugh if
you want to have fun well we want to
fulfill everybody's fantasies well
fulfilling life and having a lot of sex
inside while we do it so why not have
these stars live all through our
fantasies as long as you're paying for
it right okay so that's the biggest
thing as long as you're paying for it do
you think it should be us you know all
the tube sites are ruining the business
and if people still want the amount of
porno that we all make for y'all to keep
coming out some people gotta be buying
it because who's gonna pay us right
that's a good point so are there site do
you recommend if people want to actually
support the business that they go to yes
I recommend the elegant angel they just
released two squirting show cases of
mine actually I'm gonna say their first
oh wow a good one
of different angel ones we got a little
bit of crotch archery huh yeah
now I so but now do you think there
should be a special section on on these
sites where the you know it should say
that these are deceased if this is where
you want to come to see deceased porn
pornographic actresses well I mean if
you're gonna Google one of your favorite
stars some of the pages that will come
up first like your free ones and things
like that will we'll have I don't know
it's the most politically correct way to
say this but like year of deaths perhaps
there's you know something like that
okay and so do you think well now what
about I thought maybe would be
interesting if they had like an in
memoriam at the end of a poor you know
at the say you're watching some porn at
the end there's like you know do you
think that would turn people off like
you're you know spraying out next thing
you know you know it's like you know
Judy you know was you know left the
earth in 2015 I wonder if that would
like I could kill some people can't be
yeah I can see you know interfere with
your a little after come euphoria there
yeah I don't really know what the best
way to have people find out as your
favorite well that's the way or not but
a good question I don't know if that's a
good idea or not to have that do you if
you pass away and I hope you never do I
want to tell you that yeah I mean I just
hope the world just gets to see your
skin and your you know breasts and you
know anus and legs and everything for
decades to come
yeah okay yeah good good and but if you
ever do do you want men to still be
jerking off to your material I mean
that's why I do it yeah do you think
there should be a clause maybe that that
that that that people who work in porn
put into their car like like you know
with the driver's license you have to
get a thing it sounds like yeah I'm
willing to donate my organs if I die you
know mm-hmm do you think they should
have something like that for you guys
maybe where it's like oh well yeah if
you know if I die
okay with people still I mean though the
purpose of that would really only be
some fans because the companies honestly
don't give a [ __ ] if they're still
making money on it they're still gonna
make money I'm right either way
Wow so final say what would you say to
this guy then we had a guy who called in
he said is it okay to be jerking off to
dead people if if I don't is it okay to
be jerking off to dead porn stars I
think yes because they made all that
content for you to jerk off to you yeah
I don't see why then being here or not
being here would have anything but I
can't see how that is very good question
yeah yeah it certainly made me think
well um I appreciate you taking some
time to talk to us you guys can follow
Zoe Munroe on our Instagram at Miss MS
Zoe Monroe MO in RO e but beware if you
go to Instagram Z you're probably going
to end up taking a 15-minute break from
work so one leads to the other you know
so I try to stay off your Instagram
sometimes because you know I just can't
really control myself you know so I just
have issues when it comes to self
control hey we all do yeah yeah that's
true I guess we all do well I appreciate
you discussing
I appreciate you discussing us
discussing this with us and and thank
Zoe and you have to come on come on the
podcast sometime we'd love to have you
you bet have a good evening good luck
with the hammock in the bone oh yeah all
right all right bye so there you go she
says you know that's what the material
is made for it's made to be out there
it's made for people to you know get
that jerk up and get that seed up now I
feel like there should be a thing at the
end you know it's like you know would
that be a turn-off though you know
you're you know you know you're
squeezing and pleasing yourself you know
and just treating your wiener like a
damn [ __ ] near-empty too
of toothpaste you trying to get that
last you know that last pop because
that's the thing when I'm masturbating
it's like at this point it's when I was
young it would just be like you know
just get that thing to fire and just
watch that thing fire you know part of
them part of me and I always have
thought I'd be good at archery because
part of me the best thing about
masturbation was that pop not even the
feeling I would get but just a joy of
seeing that distance you know seeing
that hit you know seeing that uh that
trebuchet you know how far that Boulder
is gonna go is it gonna you know what do
you know just seeing what kind of you
know you're like dang that's going on
side of my body I got that electricity
coming out about body you know I got
that uh you you know that Satan's
neutrons and they're flying out of your
frickin body and out of your nuts and
that was exciting to me but then I do
notice that as I get over time I just
want to get as much joy as I can before
I you know it you know end up you know
spraying out I try to get as much like
build-up of sheer joy before I end up
you know catching that pop so it's kind
of evolved a little bit as to what
masturbation is for me but I'll say this
though I think that you should know as
viewers maybe we watch and do a little
bit of you know maybe you do something
before you light a candle you know I got
a candle lit right here even just for
this conversation because I knew we was
definitely gonna be delving into the
darts into the dark arts and so you like
that candle you know or maybe you do a
put some oranges out like they do in
India they something they have a little
picture of you know Ganesh the elephant
and a couple of oranges or a little
potpourri Zoar something you know you
light up a couple of candles or throw
some sage around the room if you know
whoever you're gonna masturbate to is
deceased you know maybe you take it on
that yourself as a person to have a
little bit of because I think it's arson
aliy do think it's a little bit wild to
be cracking on you know some deceased
footage of somebody I guess
that's a good question because here I am
changing my mind mid-sentence it's a
good question but I feel like for me I
would feel better and I try to stay away
from pornography but for me I would feel
better if I didn't do it if I did not do
that if I did not watch it at all but I
would then feel better if there was a in
memoriam at the end you know you you
know you spank you you know you know
you're you know stack and skeet inside
of your body and stack in the second the
second a stack and you're watching and
then you know at the end it says you
know you know Molly tit butt or whatever
name was you know MA whatever the look
the girl's name was Molly but but you
know tits and butt ass or whatever you
know something sexier than that
obviously Lopez make her fancy you know
she was you know alive from you know
2000 to 2019 and you like whoa I think
it would make it more real I think
things like that would make it more real
and maybe you throw in a couple of other
stats you know she liked to uh you know
she liked to The Fast and the Furious
series and she had a couple of bad
tattoos as she was saving up money to
get removed or something like that
something makes her a little bit more
personal that could be interesting but
then like like Zoey said a lot of that
is fantasy a lot of that is that you
know you want the fantasy so if they had
it at lea know if a headstone you know
if you had a headstone section a fee of
pornography would that kill the fantasy
and I could see also how it very well
could
so yeah I think if you life you light
some candles or do some special stuff
maybe you know get out one of those um
you know a lot of times and some of the
churches they'll have these little the
man the preacher will go the the priest
will go up and down the house with this
wand full of holy water and just you
know he's just basically doing that
that's just skating out of his own wand
you know but it's water
you know it's spirit ski basically it's
holy water and he's throwing that on
people to get everybody hyped up about
that you know about about about the you
know about the Lord
good for everyone he's getting everybody
hyped up but if you did that maybe or
something around your house you throw
some sage or you do something
spectacular before you in delve into it
you know so you got a little bit of
protection of something good in your
heart before you're out there jerking
off to the deceased because any way you
look at it in the end you are jerking
off to the deceased so that's that's one
way to see it here's some other ways to
see you guys had some calls that came in
here we go a man this is Brandon Carr
from San Diego I actually just saw your
show at the Brea improv anyway I'm
calling in regards well I appreciate
that you noticed he didn't say it was
good I think he might have been at the
Saturday night Late Show thank you for
coming out Brandon though I do
appreciate you man onward yeah the
gentleman they call in the last podcast
asking if it was right to be jerking us
who deceased porn stars you know there's
two ways to look at this I think the one
way is like you know you're thinking man
is this girl's dead in the ground like
this is her ghost [ __ ] this dude like
can I even get hard to this if I can
like even shine that to this like you
just feel right now that's a good point
there's two moments there should I get
hard to this because getting hard to
something that's pretty that's one thing
but catching that bust that's another
thing you know freaking letting out that
you know that [ __ ] that you know just
letting that [ __ ] that nut goose fly
out of your wand that's something that's
that's another thing it's two different
things so I'm glad you're saying this
homeward and you know I get that you can
get creeped out going down that that
path but there's another way to look at
it too and that's that you know these
girls
this was their their passions of their
career this is a lot of them loves what
they did you know and it was an art to
them I just think about like when
Michael Jackson died man like the radios
were blowing his long ago four weeks
afterwards a melon you know people still
listen to this music now it's I think
that you can still have that connection
with even a porn star - it's just
another medium of entertainment isn't it
do you
that's a good point I mean it could be
like the Mona Lisa people still go see
that I mean early pornography when you
think about it is in all these books and
the road in and all those like all these
famous old painters he's you know Peter
Paul Rubens I think the man's name was
they would paint all these women and
they would put him in these bit you know
is usually kind of rubenesque sort of
net you know healthy regular looking
girls and they would put him in these
magazines they a lot of time they'd be
laying in the woods or have like a apple
Niram or a couple of pieces of fruit or
some usually fruits or something like
that or maybe someone there'd be a fox I
feel like in the back like a little like
a fox or maybe a little animal but
usually it was like them just lay in
there you know long pretty hair and that
was that was early pornography you know
that was it and no that is now
considered collectors art I mean some of
those paintings are worth so it's a
baffling amount of money but that I mean
look pornography is is so popular you
would not believe it pornography had V
the first videos you could watch online
were pornography think about that now
everything is video the first ones you
could watch online or pornography
pornography has led the X the explosion
and the dissemination I don't think
that's what the word is but it's led
like after the Bible was printed you
know once a print but the the Bible was
printed after that pictures of freaking
late he started milling around you know
you'd attitudes walking three you know
three nights out into the desert to dig
up a picture of old you know the
original camel toe that they had hid out
there to jerk off and that was and
that's what was going on you know when
when the internet started and people
were one of the first the biggest
catalogues of collected images one of
the first the first and biggest was
pornography people look in the jerk-off
people want to look at the Constitution
make sure it was real basically just
Xerox is of it or whatever
they could see online and then there was
huge catalogues of pornography when the
Berlin Wall fell here's a fact for you
in the Berlin Wall fell a lot of
pornography could get out of there
people needed money so you could buy
there was ease like moguls ease at
pornography moguls who were buying you
know for a hundred bucks they get a you
know you know 200 images of a sexy you
know Polish girl or German girl and then
they would sell subscriptions to people
online on some of these early sites and
and they'd sell him for a ton of money
was MIT they were making so much money
it was crazy but Pournami them with the
first thing they get if you I bet you if
you go back to hieroglyphics I bet they
got the first thing you see is like a
fire a little bit of directions maybe a
recipe somebody drew like some wheat and
a plus you know a picture of some you
know maybe a Boar's hip or something or
a you know a cut of arc or a [ __ ]
pheasant or a damn moose or something
you know plus water water pot equals and
then you know they draw pictures of
people eating together but but if you
walk down that cave and look probably
behind a little bit of a rock or a few
pit you know few pictograms over
somebody sketched out some crotch or
some coot or some pornography it's a
huge business it's heavy it's big it's a
big thing
it might even start to but who've them
to have a section that is you know
epitaph porn or you know rest in you
know rest and porn that could be a cute
little section they could do so well I'm
curious to see as more and more porn
stars die how do they embrace this as an
industry you know I wonder if they still
get residuals off of that I don't think
they do I think from everything that I
know a lot of these girls just get flat
fees I should have asked a Zoe that but
man if you've seen Zoe boy you got to
get out there boy she done man I wish I
could do my but can not even do any of
those tricks and I'm grateful that it
can't but she really got I mean she's
man make you get off the bus
boy and walk out in the woods dude man
Mickey get out there and be alone by
yourself and be by yourself
okay let's catch a couple more responses
here here's one more beer dealer man G
from Phoenix I'm just calling in about a
J P's question jerking off to dead porn
star I think that that it would be
disrespectful not to because that's kind
of like that's their art form you think
if Denzel Washington died he would want
us to stop watching training day if
anything you should have a marathon and
watch all of them I don't know if you
can do that in a row especially some of
these bigger ones to take this such a
volume of work it just translates like
that Denzel would want us to remember
the Titans
not black it out and not ever watch it
again well true that's a good point but
if you remember in the Titans you know
me and you out there trying to remember
them you know I'm not jerking off to
Remember the Titans
you know that's the thing you know I'm
not out there jerking off to uh you know
sergeant Sully lands the plane or
whatever that movie was so that's the
thing it's different if you're if you're
at the movie theater you're in Denzel
Washington's dead and you're jerking off
to whatever stand by me or something I
think you might have been in then that's
that's [ __ ] up but if you you know
with the porn starts a little different
because there is that physical
connection where there's expected to be
I think a release but I respect that I
respect that it'd be disrespectful not
to watch they did the work they put it
out there you know in 30 years this
could be like those for like that like
the books when I used to go see in the
library and I've told this story before
that when I was young I really I mean I
I was I was into pornography early and
once I saw it I mean the first real
porno magazines I found I found of my
mom well the first one this boy at the
library showed me a picture of it and
beat me up and then we had this other
kid before that you should draw you have
draw crotches if you wanted to see a
crotch had to get him to draw you one
because this do was I mean he was just
like
Jarrid the jeweler i mean this dude had
the best he could draw ha he could draw
it all and that's what you get for the
weekend you know give him you know 6
bucks or something get that drawn of
crotch for the weekend but then you know
I started going to the library and
seeing these rubenesque women in these
old volumes of in the library and did I
remember I'd be so erect in there in
that library and I would take this book
and literally close the book on my
wiener you know and just kind of smash
it against it like press the book
against it on both sides until I you
know expelled joy out of my body and
that's just being young I mean I think I
was probably 12 you know and we've all
done weird stuff and I'm not proud of
that you know but I don't feel a lot of
shame of it because I just this wasn't a
time that's how if we wanted porn like
you know it was so rare to come across
so anything that would get me lit a
little bit in the crotch I would find it
and I found those men and I found those
these were encyclopedias art
encyclopedias and they had pictures from
rode in and peter paul rubens and some
of these other artists and I'd get in
there and and just look at the picture
and just close it up on my because just
that pressure on your rod at that time
at that youth with that virility going
through you I mean really brought you to
the end of um it brought you to what you
wanted you know brought you'd want to
you know get that free ounce out of your
body but here we go one more a call
right here and this came in from
Jennifer here we go
hi this is Jennifer and there was a
question about the porn star thing I
don't really think that it's wrong to
masturbate to a part are the dead I just
think it's kind of like its artwork in
its own way I guess I think if they
cared they would have wrote a will and
said when I die I take my [ __ ] offline
hi this is well and there you go
Thank You Jennifer I appreciate that
call and I'm thinking about it more now
as I'm even here now when I
woman's voice say it right there it puts
it a little bit more it makes it more
real to me a little bit you know because
the pornography that I watches women you
know I enjoy women sex and and man and
woman sex together you know I enjoy
heterosexual sex on the internet
watching that's right if I do watch
which I try not to watch anymore
sorry which I try not to watch anywhere
else what I watch but if I if I after
hearing Jennifer's voice right but after
hearing Jennifer's voice right there it
kind of I don't know it in a weird way
it just made me have a little bit more
not respect for women but it made it
more real all of a sudden that just now
just in this moment of hearing her voice
talking about it for me and this won't
be for anybody else but I think that I
would now I don't wanted to know if
they're deceased or not I think that
they should put a regulation on the porn
websites if someone is deceased but have
a little headstone pop up in the
beginning you know we're like a have a
um you know a cross or a Star of David
or a you know uh hindu statue whatever
or muslims whatever their religion was
have something you know a two-second
homage to that maybe have a you know or
have the head you know have the memoriam
you know busty barbara you know you know
1998 to 2007 you know have that bust up
every now and then or that's that old
enough he okay good
yeah like have that pop up every now and
see at least you know what's going on
but I would like that and I would
because otherwise I don't want to be out
there busting nuts too I don't I don't
want to be out there ejaculating to the
deceased and you know why because
there's tons of women on the websites
who are not deceased and that sits
better in my soul so I think that these
sites should have a little bit of
respect and put the women into a special
a special folder or a special you know
sight box or whatever that says you
the graveyard or whatever you know so
that it then at least you can have oh
you can masturbate slower or you can
wear something nice while you masturbate
or you can have some regard for the pack
for the fact you can light some candles
like I said you could do the sage you
could do whatever you could have some
regard for the path for the fact that
these women are no longer alive because
I don't think when I get to the the
reckoning spot or whatever it is you
know when I get into that that great big
cliff in the air and the spirit that's
out there the higher power whatever it
is says jump and that's when you find
out if they gonna if they you know if
the big dull gonna catch you in his hand
or the big woman wherever she wherever
it is or they gonna let you fall down
into the smithereens
and a dragon is just gonna [ __ ] eat
your legs off while you're falling
through the air I don't want that to be
well I don't want that to be another
anvil that's weighing down in my body
deep in my soul that I was uh that I was
you know I was making free ones to to
the deceased I don't want it
and simply because there's enough work
out there where I don't need it so I'll
take that right there what else on one
side about the game dude I still don't
know who won I could easily see that
Minnesota completed two passes and got
in field goal range I could easily see
that what else right here I'm gonna
check in that's it man had some more
stuff wanted to get into but this is in
the news I'm gonna hit this news story
real quick a man claiming to be a police
detective went to his local adult porn
shop and demanded they give him free
porn videos so he can make sure none of
the performers were underage what a smut
Muppet he made three attempts within a
nine day span when the store owner
finally
had had enough and called the police
this man is still in the run
if you encounter a man claiming to be
with the sorry this is making me laugh
is not cool with the age verification
unit make sure you don't give him any of
your porn for free and alert the police
immediately
and like Zoe said right there man a few
minutes ago you know hit those hit hit
the sites that she mentioned pay for the
pay for the pool and get the good stuff
get involved support your artists you
know if I if Picasso said hey man you
want to come watch me paint you're like
not a slick a child [ __ ] all the time
he's like it's $3 to get in here and
watch me sketch something out would you
go watch him you know bust one you know
a [ __ ] series of color nuts out of
his hand and imagination would you go
watch him paint and make something you
might instead of just looking at his old
[ __ ] so support that support that we
have two more calls that came in
actually one was an email that I wanted
to get some maybe some suggestions you
guys might have if anybody out there has
kids you guys might have some
information on this I'm gonna tell you
my upcoming dates this weekend I'll be
at the new comedy club in Jackson
Jacksonville Florida
that's the 18th through the 20th I'll be
at Harveys in Portland February 8th
through 11th February 16th through the
18th I'll be at La Jolla California at
the Comedy Store
February 22nd through the 24th I'll be
in Indio California fantasy Springs and
April 6th and 7th I'll be in Tampa
Florida at Rock Brothers brewing there's
also I think March 22nd and 23rd I'll be
in Tacoma Washington let's hit one more
call right here here we go hi my name is
Nicole I'm calling from Houston Texas
thank you for your call Nicole onward
I'm a stay-at-home mom I have a young
boy and I'm expecting another young boy
here in a few months
Oh congratulations he's gonna have a
brother you know that's pretty special
I'm thinking you know you can't really
plan a hell you can't really plan ahead
on a lot of that you know to um you know
I don't think you know as a parent maybe
you don't know what you're creating when
you make a brother for a kid but that
can be I mean there's no other
relationship like
so you know I commend you on being brave
enough to have two children because
you're not only creating you're gonna be
creating a relationship with you and
your son you're gonna be broadening your
family but you were giving a kid a
brother and there's nothing you know I
can't explain to you you know I'm
fortunate enough to have a brother and I
can't explain you what that relationship
is like it hasn't always been great but
it's just so it's so great to have a
brotherhood to be able to to compare and
navigate how I'm supposed to behave
towards other men and how and have
someone who already is a little bit of a
blueprint of myself out there to look at
and feed off of to get ideas and
Inklings for things and get some advice
and some suggestions so you're really
creating something awesome so I commend
you for that
onward and I along with what seemed like
my entire community of girlfriends we
were all professionals that chose to
stay at home and when that happened we
saw that we were underserved in the
capacity that we're taught how to be
great employees great co-workers but we
have never been taught how to manage a
home and to raise children you know do
all of those things a bit more
traditional and nature so my question to
you is especially since we you have
talked to us a lot about the sort of war
against men the culture of
irresponsibility which we all see that's
happened and is happening what are some
things that you as a man would advise
new moms to instill in their young sons
to be later good men does that make
sense I hope so
hi my name's Nicole and that just
circles back around Herc also knows it
just plays if I let it go through it
starts back over but that's a great
question let's hear the very end of it
again here we go one more time are some
things that you as a man would
wise new moms to instill in their young
sense to be later good men that does
make sense I started to clear my throat
there um it does make sense if you know
I think spending time with them one on
one as they get a little bit older you
know as they get to be like five six
seven eight
spend some time just separately go do
something separate with your son you
know one of the only things ever got to
do with my mom that was just me and her
was uh we went to Wendy's one time and I
know that doesn't sound like a lot but
and I probably have talked about this
before but um you know my mother worked
all the time you know she didn't want us
to be on welfare so she worked and I'm
not saying that she's better than your
mom I'm not saying that she's better
than your grandmother she's any debt I'm
not saying anything like that I'm just
saying that and I think she worked
sometimes too because she was probably
stressed out from having four children
she didn't know what else to do maybe
sometimes so she did what she knew how
to do which was to work but one time I
was sick or something I couldn't be at
school I could have gotten you know
expelled maybe are not expelled but
suspended and so I had to go to work
with my mom and we rode around it's like
different cities or whatever were
delivering like magazines she was
delivering magazines at the time and
we're delivering these magazines and it
was just kind of cool because I got to
be with her it was just me and her and
we went to Wendy's for lunch and I'd
never went to a lunch place just with me
and my mom before you know and and we we
there was too long of a line inside so
we went through the drive through and we
got sandwiches and we just rode around
and ate them and I'm sure I'll was
probably an [ __ ] that day but you
know it's a typical kid but I looking
back our remember it is like one of my
favorite times where I got to spend time
with just me and my mother so I would
just make sure that you know or I don't
know make sure I don't have a family but
I think that that's important to make
sure there's some connection there and
then you know I think try not to tell
your son you don't always want to hear
what what we'll do better sometimes he
just wants you to love him and just let
him know that he's okay
and to you know let him know that you
love him that's it you know sometime a
kid doesn't always hear how it could be
better or how he could have done it
different or what because they don't
they don't that's that's adult stuff you
know and I've struggle with that over my
life telling people what could they
could do better you know sometimes
people just want to hear that they're
not alone and especially your kid well
your son will want to hear that and then
I would take some control and I would I
would talk to him about how he treats
women because I don't think that's a
conversation that just both men need to
have with their sons anymore I do think
that that's a conversation that women
need to have and I commend you I think
that the the toughest thing a woman can
do is be a mom and to manage the home
and to take the risk of there being less
income in the home to stay at home and
create that family but if we can get out
of what the world tells us is good and
we can get back into what our heart
tells us is right or good I'm not gonna
say right that's not the word but feels
good then I think you know we'll find a
lot of times that it's that it's that
that it's being with our family you know
and having those fun times and having
those you know ridiculous my favorite
time that I ever had when I was young
was when the power went out and my
family would all be together and we
couldn't fight or beat each other
because I had candles lit and it's
dangerous to beat each other around
candles so we would just be together and
we were kind of scared and nervous but
we were all together like in one place
you know my mom had two candles and so
we would have to be by her and we would
have to be together and it was just I
don't know there was something special
about that so you know I think those are
a few things but that might be some good
calls man maybe we can do that have a
couple of calls that come in about that
if you guys have some thoughts on that
you know and that's you know you heard
her question and I appreciate that
question i'ma play for you guys one more
here we go that's happened and is
happening what are some things that you
as a man would advise new moms to
instill in their young sons to be later
good men did that make n yeah it does
make sense and I mean some of those
there's gonna be general regular things
but I think I would love to hear some
answers on this question for today for
today's society today's times because
there is some evolution that needs to
happen in I think some of the ways that
we communicate what we can't help me
evolution is happening you know it's
like we have to communicate now on you
know cellular devices and you know I
think so it's got to be a lot harder for
parents so maybe I don't know what so
I'd love to maybe hear if you guys have
some stuff I had some more awesome calls
that came in and I wanted to get to some
of them I just have to go to this comedy
set guys I'm sorry but I will be back on
Thursday and we'll get into some more
good stuff dude you guys stay safe out
in Hawaii they had a mailman Emma in
Louisiana that finally finally admitted
to burning all the mail instead of
delivering it and you know what dude
that's [ __ ] awesome but also go [ __ ]
yourself brah you know Marc Wayne
Thompson pled guilty to delay or
destruction of mail Thompson admitted
that instead of delivering mail he just
took it home with him and burned it as a
result he now faces up to five years in
prison or three years supervised release
that's hilarious
what you in for man oh you know [ __ ]
cooking up a batch of cooking up up
cooking up a batch of Bed Bath & Beyond
coupons ha ha what is the world coming
to
I don't know but I think we can embrace
it with a smile as it does you know
there is dark stuff going on out there
you know porn stars are dying people are
jerking off to dead people on the
internet and you might not like the way
I frame that but that's a real framing
that is a real framing boy that's
Michael's that's done in the back of my
you know it it's more expensive than you
thought that's real framing you know but
there's still also those mothers out
there who asking how can they help and
do and raise their kids and they want to
know from kids who have grown up what
could your mother or your mother what
did she do or what could your mother
have done that you think would have
helped you along the way and that is a
good way I think we can frame that
question so I appreciate you guys as
calls man I appreciate where they came
out in brea hope to see you guys soon
we'll do some ads in the upcoming
episode oh that's my brother
what's up Z hey all right dude don't
tell me what happened no no I didn't
look do not tell me well that's why I
didn't that I wouldn't tell you anything
hey no actually this is a perfect ending
because I'm just finishing on my podcast
is the very end and I don't know what
happened I paused it right after the
Saints kicked their field goal there was
25 seconds left and you're on the
podcast now and I can take this off
later if you want but but why don't you
tell me what happened I want to know
well yeah I mean now's the time to
notice almost I mean I'm just finishing
the podcast is the perfect time and we
were just talking about a brotherhood
and stuff Oh a minute ago so this is
kind of it's perfect I'm gonna tell you
about ten minutes about Who I am
yeah well 10 seconds left
the third ten or whatever they need
about 20 yards to get a field goal race
25 yards anymore dad and you know like
this is a one in a hundred chance that
the Saints lose 1% yeah he threw it to
Avon Diggs whatever same is do caught it
like 40 right right about probably four
feet from the sidelines Marcus Williams
was right there mm-hmm Holly has it was
literally pull him to the ground but for
some weird reason but Avon digs jumped
in the
Marcus Williams like Jove underneath him
I don't know what he was doing I think
you trying to up in them or something
hmm
and when he didn't even momentum I mean
clearly missed him
beat he rolled into the other corner
back all-new it might even lead him on
who it was there and save on days just
ran in the end zone no they got a
touchdown yeah dude they were like on
our 35 ya know in their own 35 or 40
yeah second one percent chance we had a
lot we would lose that game at that
point
damn a loss like that similar to Tampa
Bay but I didn't see the end of the tape
of a game but I'm just gonna be hard
rings yeah
it was a hard break man it really was
because I think we win that game we're
down 17 another half
yeah no I think we win going in there
like a 30 40 percent shot and we came
back and really played really well the
seconds happened yeah you just made such
a weird play I don't know what he was I
really know what he was doing I can't
figure it out you know hey David they
contained him will I mean it was like a
last-ditch effort basically what it was
and I just don't see how yeah but it
happens you know it's over now it's over
I still can't believe it but it is over
but enemies you have the weirdest stuff
too damn man we had we I died yeah I
thought I figured we had we have a
really really good shot here man um
alright damn dude you out there boy um
quick question so actually we had a lady
that called in and she said what is
something she's about to have her second
child and she said what is something
that that mothers can do with their sons
these days to help make them better men
and it's kind of a question for mothers
but it's also a question for sons what
do you think is one thing a mother can
do with their children to make them
better man there's done yeah or
something they could talk to him instill
in him I don't know that I think it was
it was a little bit broad but yeah well
you know I don't know I thought you can
do
those children are young to make them
better men when they get older mm-hmm
for that some of the know some of the
that male stuff be Lerman they're a
little bit older but when they're young
I think the best thing mother could do
is connect with emotionally connect with
their children of the emotionally
available yeah
oh don't make sure that the child knows
that their behavior does not determine
your love for them even if it makes you
upset
what they do when you don't do and you
can have another thing you know is you
can tell children early on you can
explain certain things to them you might
simplify it but they will understand you
right I don't got enrolled you know up
and telling them I'm 4 year old where
the six and five now but we've been
since there were four so mad at you it
doesn't mean I don't love you hmm what
you do I love you
mmm now that's what you do may get you
in trouble but it has it's as you and
then they understand it you know yeah
now that's my girls yeah my five year
old is now your madam you don't love me
you'll say that max was like that who
say no it doesn't mean that it means
that I'm mad at you so you kind of you
know you just kind of helped him along
an emotional availability and accept the
unconditional love is what they need I
mean that's you know one time like in
life that he's unconditional lover
Morris's father a parents house
especially mother child I mean they have
to be able to they have to know that you
love in the matter what they do if they
kill somebody when they're eight or ten
I'm not say I'm just an extreme example
you know they got some young they got
some young hitters out there yeah the
amount you know the amount of your love
should not waver now yeah because you're
the only place that can get that right
and you may choose not top simmer be
extremely disappointing I talk to them
for a year whatever but you know so that
thing it's real important you know cuz
sometimes in our society where our worth
is built on what we do what we don't do
and I think that a lot of that starts to
parent you know when the children yo
yeah you can fill that tank up early and
let them know that now that they look
man
I'll even just liked hearing that you
know that not what you know my behavior
if I would have heard that when I was
young I think I would have might be a
little bit of a healthier person today
you know yeah let me - you know me -
yeah alright man well I appreciate you
calling I'm gonna call you later cuz I
got to run a literate to drive straight
to Brea right now I was crash love you
day in love YouTube that's my brother
Zephyr II know he lives down and um he
lives in Baton Rouge Louisiana but yeah
it gets an interesting answer he loved
he really likes to think about this kind
of stuff and he loves to be a parent and
I mean his wife is a is a stay-at-home
mom and that's a CEO in my book you know
I mean if I could go back in time and
it's just got me a little bit emotional
but if I could go back in time and have
anything I would have that you know I
mean I can't even imagine what that
would be like you know to just you know
just be at home and be having fun to be
comfortable and have your mom around you
know so but anyhow dude you [ __ ] you
guys have hit me in a heartbeat here at
the end but that's a great question
we'll leave it right there I had a
lovely young a gentleman mr. Ochoa who a
messaged and he's afraid to call in he
had a he had a question I thought was
interesting but we're gonna get to that
on Thursday brother so if you're out
there hold the line and we'll see you
then if you have questions hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three I'm running to Brea
I appreciate you guys be good to
yourselves you probably deserve it
[Music]